greets everyone I'm Alana and welcome to
my channel I'm actually recording the
intro of this video after having already
finished making this video because I
decided that I'm probably gonna have to
split this into two pots right now you
are watching a Red Dead Redemption 2
gameplay talk-through I made one of
these for cyberpunk and people seem to
really enjoy that so basically what I'm
going to do for the first part of this
is just straight-up talk through
everything that I saw from my three
hours getting hands-on time with Red
Dead Redemption to the second part of
this video will be an FAQ / Q&A for
answering all of the questions people
have been asking me on social media
about the game so I'll probably upload
that a day after I up uploaded this one
you guys I feel like I cannot overstate
how high my expectations were going into
seeing this game it's a rockstar game I
knew it was going to be good it had to
do so much to impress me and it did we
start with the story mission it's a very
snowy area as you're riding with a group
of members of Dutchess gang who I want
to say more like a community than a
family but they're ultimately a team of
people who very much respect Dutch
including author who is the main
character if you didn't know so you're
following Dutch through the snow and it
looks so cinematic particularly because
everything on the horses is individually
rendered Rockstar told us that when we
were like how is it all bouncing so
beautifully each pot of the saddle and
each cloth and every different
attachment you have on the saddle
because you have to actually store
things on your horses saddle in its pack
meaning that you can upgrade it it can
all have different all of that is
rendered but it's also just I was paying
a lot of attention to this the prints in
the snow from the horses hooves are
actually where they step it really looks
like where they step where you put the
horse is exactly where the hoof print
falls into the snow I promise I won't
get stuck in the tiny details of the
whole thing like this but I want to
paint a picture of just how detailed
this is so you're writing sort of
through a mountain you can jump into the
cinematic mode there which is very
similar to GTA v but dramatically
improved this time around
if you hold X it keeps you with the
group automatically so that you don't
have to steer all or try
keep up and the dialogue is fully
fleshed out almost non-stop very similar
to how the car rides feel in gta' but
with more people so there's more depth
to it so we get to this sort of peak
that's overlooking a train there is
character down there who is doing
something to the tracks and Dutch orders
Arthur to go down and help him so you go
down there
very simple thing happens you're just
helping someone rigged explosives to the
Train I won't talk about who that person
is go back up the hill you also watch
author adjust in his seat to ride up a
hill he will physically shift his weight
so that he can move upwards it's bonkers
and there's been a mistake the explosion
does not happen it has been rigged
incorrectly so you jump on the train it
happens to be going under a bridge you
and other members of the gang run
through the snow you leave your horses
sort of on that ledge we established
before you jump on the top of the Train
two of them don't make it and two of you
do the other person who made it is
hanging on the side of the Train and you
walk over and you pick them up
I asked Rockstar what would happen if we
didn't walk over to pick him up and they
said he would eventually fall off so we
jumped down in between two carriages and
this is our first time experiencing an
indoor environment and just damn we
gotta open a drawer and you can see the
actual items that you can pull out of
that drawer they are actually in that
drawer again without a loading screen
all that will actually put his hand
inside and pick up each individual item
which is then transferred into your
inventory I feel like if you've never
played a video game before this wouldn't
sound impressive but for anyone who has
uh-huh I can't even really comprehend
how this game runs so shootout happens
we get off the train and trying to find
a sudden thing to loot so the Gangnam is
that of the with Dutch leading the
charge and author of course being a
handy Backup threatened people who have
hold themselves inside one lost train
caught by shooting the side of it so
you're giving those people the chance to
surrender and then going in there
getting the stuff while someone else I
think ties up their hands and then
drags them out into the snow you go in
you get the loot and again this is a
cabin with so much detail walk outside
and Dutch gives you the option of what
to do with the men who survived you had
the option to kill them or leave them
but you could also intimidate them could
shoot your gun into the air you could
pull out your revolver and pull it back
but not actually shoot it so they know
that you're like getting ready to shoot
which again actually animated he
actually physically does that as a
motion while holding a pistol revolver
or whatever I don't know [ __ ] about guns
and because oft at this point we jumped
FOID in the save a fair bit I don't know
what the consequences of those actions
actually do but it's same time after
that choice the next thing was though
the next quest objective which we did
not get to do before they jumped us
ahead was to get rid of the Train
somehow because obviously we had stopped
it trains are also used as a point of
FOSS travel but you can hijack train so
I assume you can just drive that train
away and like leave it at a station
somewhere so at this point we jumped
several hours ahead this is also why we
learn about some of the major mechanics
which I will probably talk about a
little bit more in the Q&A section so we
spawn I believe it was nighttime and one
thing about the nighttime in Red Dead is
that the sky is crazy
pretty there are so many stars you can
see galaxies up there you really can't
see a lot you can even see when storms
are going to roll in basically you'll be
able to see it in the distance that
there are a lot of clouds so you can be
like oh there's probably a storm if I go
that way which you can use to your
advantage because you can wash your
horse by riding through the rain and you
do need to wash your horse if they get
super muddy it'll start to slow them
down at this point we actually decided
to do some almost bonding so bonnie was
your horse is super important because
the more you bond with it the more
likely it is to remain calm in a
high-stress situation like for example
the horse we were riding seemed to have
seen a rattlesnake or something and so
therefore like kind of panicked while we
were trying to do dressage and if you
don't have a good relationship with your
horse and you walk behind it it will
kick you just like in real life so yeah
now we're just walking around this nice
open world you walk past this dead
rotting animal that's on the side don't
know what or who killed that but it it
starts rotting and that will become
important in a bit but we decided to
talk to some NPCs which is just as cool
as everyone has been making it sound
any NPC that you find if you hold down
l2 you can greet Rob or dismiss them
those are your immediate interactions
with any NPC and it should be mentioned
you are not locked into anything when
you talk to an NPC it's just like
talking to someone you're passing in the
street you don't have to like stop and
have an encounter and you can talk to
every single NPC they all have something
different to say a lot of them have jobs
they all have places they are going and
that's the thing that's hardest for me
to understand about Red Dead Redemption
- how do they have all of these things
in this one world that all function in
real time horses even poop dynamically
you can pat dogs dogs will remember you
and the next time that you see them
they'll know that you've patted them and
won't bark at you from a distance if
they're like a god dog it's crazy
back on track ok so talking NPCs you can
also antagonize them and call out to
them calling out to them is handy if
you've lost your horse you can ask
someone to take you to town but
basically the way conversations work I
like you and tagging eyes them is mean
to them greeting them is the polite
introduction so you can choose to like
have the conversation head in a negative
way or in a positive way you could also
start a fight with them and then select
defuse which would kind of like take it
down a few levels then kill them anyway
basically every conversation should feel
different and for us in that first part
way we're just talking to everyone who
walked past it did feel different every
time some of them are nice some of them
are you get to talk to you some of them
seem like people who are agitated
because they're in a rush and they're
mad that you're disrupting them they
will also react to you based on how much
blood is on you how muddy you are they
might react to you if you look tired
because you haven't slept in a while if
you look skinny because you haven't
eaten in a while because that's all
stuff that happens in this game so after
talking to a few NPCs we actually
noticed that the caucus we'd spotted
earlier was being eaten by wildlife
which is also a thing that will happen
if you leave a caucus somewhere we
didn't leave that one there just happen
to be that it will degrade over time and
will attract wild animals you can use
that when not hunting if you would like
to so we saw some smoke on the top of a
hill I'm alike alright I'll check that
out so we walked up there out of
curiosity and there was just a guy
sitting there not really doing anything
we get off a horse and we are wearing a
black hat we probably have some negative
renown out on a system is in the
negative at this point we've been kind
of a dick so this guy stands up and
reacts and is
what are you doing here what do you want
because you are at his campfire why he's
just sitting there he seems to be eating
if I remember correctly he's got a horse
hitched he's got a little tent and you
know we kill him
we just really we really just shoot him
which led us to crafting you can croft
at campfire auth is also a really good
cook so you can you can make food but I
think it's also like weapons ammo
upgrades everything is very very
customizable so you can do that at camp
fight but Rockstar did mention that
there might be different things you
could craft at a campfire as two things
you could craft elsewhere so then we
looted some of his stuff as well you can
pick up a lot of different kinds of
things I think we even stole his hat it
knocked him off and you can put his hat
on funnily enough the mini-map will say
when you last left your hat which i
think is really cute so that's you know
it keeps an eye on where your hat is
you've got his hat and then we picked
him up and dumped his body somewhere so
as to not be suspicious and one thing
about carrying things meaning you know
if you're carrying a body again blood is
going to get on you because you're
carrying a bloody body it will decrease
your stamina if you're walking while
carrying something we dumped him and
then walked back down the hill but did
it in a way that was video gaming we
decided to just run right down that hill
and in doing so seemed to have like
broken a horse's leg this is one part of
the game that I'm wondering how
punishing it will be so many people I
used to moving very quickly in video
games even while riding a horse
shoutout to Roche from The Witcher
people are used to treating them like
they're not very fragile so as to get
from A to B as fast as possible and I
think you will spend a lot of time on
horseback in this game but we did have
horse tonic or like some kind of steroid
that we could use to heal the horse so
everything ended up fine there and then
we headed towards the nearest town which
we could see in the distance but
actually got intercepted by another gang
member Xavier in a random encounter and
I think this part is particularly really
cool
this wasn't a side quest this wasn't a
main quest this was just us going across
a road and having him come towards us
and be like hey author I need your help
we could have just kept riding could
have completely ignored him but he came
up to us with a lot of urgency so I you
know I wanted to respond to him we asked
what was up and OspA details and
apparently another one of the gang
members
been kidnapped so he was like come on we
need to rescue him let's go get and so
we did and again this is not a side
quest this is a gang member who would
usually be at the camp who you know in
previous rockstar games if it were a
core character or someone who was
involved in the story would usually just
be in the house that has their letter on
it and be someone you have to go to to
get a quest whereas he was just [ __ ]
coming up to us and so we went to this
camp where they had him so we go to
rescue him gives us stealth options and
one cool thing about this is that when
you approach something you get into
stealthy Crouch if you hold l2 it will
give you the option to interact with
your partner so in this case it was
Xavier so we had the option to tell him
to stay back tell him to go ahead tell
him what the plan was he might even tell
you something he might like give you a
tip what tell you how to approach it
I've actually written down here
apparently the issue with Xavier as we
were saving bill was that we took too
long to follow his instructions so he
gave up and started shooting we didn't
stop the shooting they noticed us
shootout happens this is where it does
get into the gunplay I want to say it
feels more like Max Payne 3 combined
with gta5 than it does like the original
Red Dead it's sharper than both auto-aim
is there but it's not too aggressive
it's still like kind of tough so we take
them all out and then loot the camp they
have little lock boxes that have tons of
stuff in it some of that stuff you will
have to take back to your camp site and
you can sell it yourself to make money
or you can donate it to the camp so that
they will prosper basically if you don't
do that everyone will be very mad at you
basically if you want kind of doing your
thing to help the community people will
realize and point it out to you and be
like ok dude you're not pulling your
weight what are you doing and I think
that moment the moment where we were
like you know not following Javier's
instructions was the moment where I
first fully appreciated the music there
are a hundred and ninety two pieces of
dynamic skull and the thing about it
that I think is really cool is that the
skull is different based on how
honorable you are want so it's like a
Paragon renegade system based on how
good or bad you are the music that plays
will be different and the way it builds
is beautiful the layering is beautiful
we finish that up we got bill got the
loot and Xavier and Bill headed back to
the camp we headed into town finally
first things first walking into the town
I was just blown away the town just has
so many people just walking around it's
not scripted it's not you walking into
town with a cutscene so naturally
they're NPCs in the background it's just
you walking into a town and everyone
existing this was a small town but again
the detail was beautiful the mud on the
ground was one thing that looked
particularly beautiful
speaking of mud that led us to take a
buff he walked into the in the innkeeper
recognized AUSA and seemed nervous in
response to seeing him basically again a
previous part of the save had had author
caused some kind of ruckus in that town
we've gotten in a bar fight with someone
called Tommy apparently and everyone
even happened to remember that it was
Tommy
that we had gotten into a fight with I
don't know if that happened in the story
I don't know if that happened
just for fun I don't know if that was
scripted but people even if you pay off
a bounty you will still remember bad
things that you have done so NPCs will
still remember them you just won't have
like a wanted or a heat level so I went
to take a bath to wash off blood and mud
and get clothes cleaned and a woman came
in and helped this wasn't a sex minigame
so then we left and headed to the saloon
West someone she is disregarding the
Tommy fight and the bartender was like
you're not gonna cause any trouble now
ayah again not scripted
this isn't scripted this is just every
NPC having a recollection of something
somehow people with some whiskey give us
the option to like just shot the whiskey
or drink it slowly and then walked
around drinking it which is the thing
that you can do now from there we went
to the barber to get a haircut you might
have heard this already but you now have
to get a haircut based on the length of
your hair you can only get it cut
shorter you can't get it cut longer but
you can also style it you can buy hair
tonic to make it grow faster and it's
very customizable like down to like the
length of each individual part of the
beard and and the pot at the top of the
hair and and it's crazy you can't only
get your head cut at ababa but you can
shave at the campsite so he can shave
himself so from there we went to the
general store looks through a catalog
and the catalog has loads of different
clothing options you can unlock clothes
from legendary pelts based on how you
execute but if you do
three star execution on an animal and
it's a rare animal then you will unlock
better clothing basically and the way to
do that is to get like a clean shot in
the head with a bow and arrow whereas if
you like shoot them with a shotgun it'll
spray bullets and you will have those
entry negs that were in stored meaning
that it would likely be a one-stop help
so the pelts that you have influenced
the clothes that you get but this is
where we also walked around and browsed
shelves and picked up things to inspect
like food a pocket watch which moves in
real time cover scent which is the thing
that helps with hunting and this bait as
well the cover scent makes it so
predators can't smell you as well
because if you are upwind from them they
will actually be able to smell off of
the stole was like another pot when my
mind was blown in it you know picking up
individual items and looking at them so
from there we walked outside and pulled
out an old-school camera took a photo
looked crispy clean which is obviously
not realistic but yes photo mode is
there which is great and then I think
somewhere in that same menu which means
it probably was the items when you took
gloves off that's also in the sort of
weapon wheel but for items toggle them
on and off if you want to we went to
looks at a stable which had a bunch of
different horses to buy and then
actually jumped into first person for
the first time which I want to say is a
lot sharper than gta5 it just feels like
it was integrated it feels like I was
playing all along whereas obviously GTA
5 I don't suspect that it was so at this
point we were just like walking around
kind of outside the town is farms people
have sheep there's a wild boar that we
came across and we're just sort of like
looking at everything in first person
and it's just so pretty
so we shot a ball a couple of times to
make sure it was really dead skinned it
in first person which was disgusting the
skinning animation takes a little while
I'm hoping that there is a way to sort
of speed it up because it does take a
fair while but you actually cut the skin
off like it's not just candid animation
third-person you don't really look at it
it's you know you've you cut that damn
skin off and it maintains the entry and
exit wounds so you'll see the bullet
holes exactly why you shot them in that
skin as you're pulling it off so we did
that and then we jumped inside one of
the pens to lasso a sheep and then
because we got a sheet we decided to
lasso a man so we did you struggled a
bunch yeah that his feet tied together
we were just sort of drag
and he was obviously not happy about it
so as soon as we took the last eye off
him Rockstar did tell us they were like
they want sure what he would do he
wouldn't necessarily automatically
attack you he might run away he might be
nice to you like it kind of depends on
who he is as a person but yes so this
guy was mad I probably would be too and
came over to punch us so we we had a
little bit of melee combat which it
definitely feels very rockstar but again
feels more precise and the thing that
really gets me is it just feels so much
more animated like it really feels a lot
more detailed like there's more than
just punch punch punch kick it's a lot
more specific and a lot more
choreographed I want to say it's not
that it's forced animations it just
looks like there's more to do
intentionally so as this guy was
punching us it was like well alright
he's tougher than he looks so you pull
on knife Auto stabbed him through the
chin just like straight up through his
chin so the guy died and it was gory as
hell people have been asking about the
gore and violence this game is
definitely gonna be gory
you can shoot someone's head off you can
shoot limbs off individually depending
on the kind of weapon that you have any
punches that you get on someone will
start to bruise and scab the faces but
as we stab this guy through the chin a
witness saw we didn't see the witness
but this has to be an actual witness
someone has to have been actually
watching the crime take place so it's
probably someone nearby and they ran to
tell the sheriff and if you can get to
the witness before they tell the sheriff
you can bribe them you can talk to them
you can you can threaten them whatever
how they react again depends on who they
are as possible they might have had an
existing relationship with that guy we
didn't see them so that's the thing that
if you're gonna just murder someone in
broad daylight you're probably gonna
need to keep an eye out just you know
murdering 101 really
and so they reported us to the sheriff
so we got a wanted level but did manage
to pay a bounty so from there we decided
to get on another horse and actually
check out the campsite for the first
time it's a lot bigger than I expected
it to be it's a lot broader it feels a
lot more like a community like a
traveling troupe people commented on the
new hat just sort of organically
mentioned liking it and as we walked in
and we're hitching our horse you know a
lady nearby just very naturally
mentioned hey someone in this town
mentioned that they wanted to see you
the idea behind that is that
pedestrians and NPCs should the
conversations you have with them should
have the same white as the conversations
you have with anyone else as the same
conversations you have a Dutch I mean
this is gonna be more with Dutch because
that's tying into the story which I
imagine all will have some emotional
journeys in it but generally no one is
gonna be any less interesting than
anyone else you know one-on-one instance
so from there um we set by the campfire
for a little bit I think drank and then
went to sleep off it does need to sleep
he will lose stamina if he doesn't sleep
basically the survival stuff generally
gives you stamina or physical effects
but won't kill you we wake up walk
around the camping in like grab some
coffee and walk while drinking it you
know walk around someone is passed out
they clearly got too drunk the night
before again unscripted that might
happen for you it might not it would
depend on what happened the night before
we go to Dutch talk about some wanted
posters that we had seen in the town
regarding the robbery that we had seen
earlier and then cut ahead to another
story mission that involved some stealth
as well I don't want to spoil it so I
won't delve into that too much but it
did have more legitimate stealth there
are throwing knives and the gang was
prompting us to use the throwing knives
but I walked up to a guy who was peeing
on a tree by himself and tried to do a
stealth takedown but it worked but I
ultimately failed because I cut him off
mid-sentence this did happen in
Wolfenstein in the new Colossus for sure
like if you try to take out one of the
leaders the commanders in that game
while they were talking people would
realize that they had stopped talking
but those are the only two games I've
encountered that this happens and so big
shootout happened I killed a lot of
people I was jumping between Cova really
really seamlessly I was covering behind
trees I could choose which part of the
tree I wanted to cover on and it feels a
lot more involved I want to say it felt
less automated and yeah the final note
that I have here that's in all caps says
everything feels important and
everything feels like a main story
mission which I really do think is one
of my biggest takeaways so that will be
the end of the first part of this video
for the Q&A which is like answering the
most common questions I talk a lot more
about customisation about horse
mechanics about just a lot of a little
finer details rather than just
exactly what I did I'll probably upload
that video in the next couple of days
yeah I just feel free to hit me up with
all the questions that you have and I
will do my best to you know be a good
resource for talking about Red Dead
Redemption thank you guys for watching I
will see y'all and next time